ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
พระครูได้ไหมคะวันนี้ไม่ได้ Share  screen
มา
เย่มาแล้วยังมาเล่นแล้วสีเขียว
จ่ายค่ะวันนี้วันอะไรคะครูฟ้าวันนี้วัน
อังคารค่ะ
นักเรียนเห็นเป็นอังคารเนาะวันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่
ผู้หญิงจะได้ 23
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคม
ปีพตอะไรคะปีพตต 2565
อาตีคศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2002  2 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวันนี้วันจันทร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
23 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมปีพศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะพรุ่งนี้
วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 25 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนพฤษภาอารมณ์ตีผช
ปีพตต
2565 ปีค.ศต.ค.ปีข้อ
2022 ค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้
เวลา 12:00 นเที่ยงกี่นาที
12:27 นาทีค่ะ
เพียง 27 นาทีนะคะโอเควันนี้นะคะครูฟ้า
ยายฮะผู้หญิงวันนี้เนี่ยเราจะมาเล่นเกม
เล่นเกมอะไรครูหญิงเนี่ยจะมีคำถาม
น้าผู้หญิงจะมีคำถามแล้วก็รู้ฟ้า
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยต้องเป็นคนตอบคำถามถ้าครูฟ้า
ตอบถูกครูฟ้าเอาชนะ
ได้อะไรครูฟ้าชนะครูหญิง
ดื่มน้ำ
เอา
ถ้าครูฟ้า
ตอบผิดแถว it ครูขวาเนี่ยแพ้อย่างเงี้ย
ครูหาแพ้ครูฟ้าดื่มน้ำเราก็จะมีแก้วน้ำมี
น้ำใช่ไหมคะถ้าครูแพ้ไม่ต้องดื่มทั้งขวด
นะก็เย้แล้วก็จะยืม
ได้ค่าครูฟ้าชนะสมัยภูฟ้าชนะครูหญิงดื่ม
น้ำ
โอเคสิ
โอเคเรามาดูคำถามเอา
ต้องเคลียร์ก่อนเดี๋ยว
เรามาดูคำถามข้อแรกให้เห็นทั้งหมดหรออ่ะ
เอาขยะนิดนึงก็ไม่ได้นะคะแป๊บนึงนะคะเขา
ก็อยากนี้หนึ่งอ้าโอเคอ่ะคำถามข้อแรกนะคะ
ครูฟ้าอ่ะเห็นว่ามีอะผมวันนี้ผม
แล้วก็เล็บมือแล้วก็เล็บเท้านะคะ
คำถามก็คือ
a เนี่ยผมดีดีเล็บมือ cc แล้วก็เล็บเท้า
เนี่ยอะไรในร่างกายเราที่มันยายาวเร็วที่
สุด
ครูฟ้าผู้หญิงเน็ตค้างเหรอคะ
5 อะไรยาวเร็วที่สุดก็คือ 1 วันเนี่ยนะ
คะครูฟ้าตามจะแยกเราสู้
0.3  3
มิลลิเมตรต่อวัน
mm  M  L เนาะครูฟ้าคิดว่าอะไรยาวเร็ว
ที่สุด
ฟ้าคิดว่า
เล็บมืออะที่ว่าเล็บมือมาหามาดูสิคะว่ากู
ฟ้าจะถ้ากูฟ้าตอบถูกครูฟ้าชนะทั่วฟ้าตอบ
ผิดผู้หญิงชนะเดี๋ยวเยอะ
เพลิน
ผิดเธอ
โปรฟ้าแพ้แพ้ครูหญิงชนะครูฟ้าดื่มน้ำผ้า
ยกแก้วขึ้นมาแล้วก็เทแก้ว
ดื่มให้หมดอ่ะใน
ระหว่างที่ครูฟ้าดื่มน้ำแล้วก็มาดูแล้ว
ไม่ดึกๆก็ขอว่าอะไรยาวเร็วที่สุด
งูผม
ผมของเราเนี่ยยาวเร็วที่สุดนะคะ
[เพลง]
ไหม
คือครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยผมยาวเร็วเล็บนะ
เล็บก็ยาวเร็วให้แต่ว่าเปรียบเทียบกันใช่
ไหมผมยาวเร็วที่สุดไม่ใช่นั้นนะนี่ก็ผิด
นะคะอ่ะกูฟ้าแผลนะคะพี่สนะ
รอต่อไป
ข้อต่อไปนะคะมีอาหารมี
Cheese หนาแล้วก็เบคอนแล้ว
แล้วก็น้ำผึ้งอ่ะอ่ะอาหาร 3 อย่างนี้ครู
บากินว่าอาหารอันไหนที่เราเก็บไว้ได้นานๆ
ไม่มีวันหมดอายุ
หมดอายุใช่มั้ยเนี่ยหมดอายุอ่ะไม่มีนะจ๊ะ
1 ปี
10 ปี
ก็โอเคกินได้ครูบาคิดว่าอะไร
ชีสเบคอนหรือน้ำผึ้ง
Cheese ฟ้าบอกว่าชีสนะคะชีสจะดูที่ว่า
ครูฟ้าจะชนะหรือว่าแพ้ถ้าแพ้ก็ดื่มน้ำนะ
คะ
สองช้าง
แค่ครูฟ้าตอบผิดนะคะก็แพ้ดื่มน้ำค่ะครู
หญิงนะมีผู้หญิง
ขอแจงสั่งเลยอ่ะมาดูนะคะว่าอะไร Day ค่อน
ก็ไม่ใช่น้ำผึ้ง
ต่อไปค่ะครูป่าวไม่เป็นไรจะรู้ก็ได้นะ
เพราะว่าอันนี้เนี่ยเราพูดถึงการดื่มแล้ว
เอ๊อะ 1:00 นแล้วนะคนเรานะอันนี้เอา
ประมาณนะคะประมาณนะ
คือเอาคนนะผู้ชายแล้วก็ผู้หญิง
ทั้งหมดที่อยู่ในโลกเลยนะอเมริกาอเมริกา
ใต้ยุโรปแล้วก็ประมาณนะประมาณนะคะ
ว่าคนเนี่ยคนเราเนี่ยถ้าไม่ดื่มน้ำไม่
ดื่มน้ำนะไม่ดื่มน้ำกี่วันตายอ้ะ
อันนี้ 3 วัน
5 วันแล้วก็ 7 วันพูดว่าคิดว่าคนเรา
เนี่ยไม่ดื่มน้ำได้กี่วัน
ก็คือถ้าไม่ดื่มกี่วันแล้วนั่นแหละอ้าวัน
ครูฟ้าบอกว่า
5 วันนะคะอ้าวอัญอันนี้เอาประมาณนะไม่
ใช่หนึ่งคนนะไม่ใช่กูมันแล้วแต่ว่าแต่ละ
ว่าประมาณเนาะเอิ่มเมื่อวันสัตว์
ค่าวันหรือสาววันให้โอกาสเรา 5 วันหรือ 3
วันน่าจะ 3 น้ำไม่ถึงหน้าหรอกน้ำดื่มน้ำ
ที่หน่อยนะไม่ดื่มน้ำตายละคนแต่ไม่ดีมาหา
กี่
3 วันหรือว่าถ้าครูฟ้าตอบถูกครูฟ้าจะชนะ
นะก็กูฟ้าตอบผิดครูหญิงแพ้อ่ะ
มี
[เพลง]
รูฟ้าชนะผู้หญิงแพ้นะครับผู้หญิงต้องเป็น
คนดื่มน้ำ
ผู้หญิงโอเคไหมโอเคค่ะ 1 แก้วโค้ชเกินไป
อ่ะทูฟ้า 1 แก้วดื่มน้ำดื่มนะดื่มน้ำดื่ม
แล้ว
เย้
อันนี้ก็น้องเฉลยผิดเนาะผิดหนอจอต่อไปค่ะ
ครูป๊า
ขอ
กูฟ้าเห็นไว้ในรูปทั้งหมดเนี่ยมันคือพริก
นะคะคลิกฤทธิ์ก็จะมีพริกอยู่ 3 ชนิดใช่
ไหมจะมีสก๊อตแบนเน็ตนะคะอุ้ยน้องเขียน
ภาษาอังกฤษไว้เพราะอะไรคะผู้หญิงจำไม่ได้
ว่ามันชื่ออะไรนะคะนักเรียนอันนี้คือ
สก๊อตแบตเน็ตนะคะส่วนดีเนี่ย Ghost เพ
อร์ฟอร์แมนซ์ cc แคลอรีนอ้า reaper ครู
ฟ้าคิดว่าพริก 3 ชนิดนี้พริกชนิดไหนที่
เพลงที่สุดในโลกเผ็ดมากที่สุด
ความคิดว่า
คาโรลิน่าลิปเปอร์ภาษาอังกฤษว่า 4 ใช่ไหม
คาโรลิน่ารีบอร์ฟาร์ทถ้ากูฟ้าแพ้ก็ดื่ม
น้ำนะใช่ตังค์ป๊าว่าน่าจะใช่
เฉลย
ทรูฆ่า
ผู้ฟ้าชนะอีกแล้วกูหญิงแท้ 1 น้ำฮ่าๆ
นี่ก็จุกน้ำขอแค่นี้นะคะนักเรียนไม่ไหว
ผู้หญิงไม่จุกหรอก
เอ็งไม่สนุกเลยเกมเพียงดื่มน้ำ
อ่ะอันนี้คือพริกที่เผ็ดที่สุดนะคะหน้าตา
ก็น่ากลัวอยู่นะไม่เหมือนคลิกเลยพี่ชาย
ข้อต่อไปนะคะอันนี้กูก็เห็นมั้ยอะไร
จรวดจะไม่จรวดแหละไปนอกโลกอะไรไปแบบดวง
จันทร์ใช่ไหมจรวดเนี่ยไปดวงจันทร์เขาไป
ดาวใช่ไหมอ่ะไปนอกโลกนะคะ
คำถาม
ก็คือก็คือครูฟ้าคิดว่า
ผักอันนี้เป็นผักนะ
อะไรเนี่ยมันฝรั่ง Map แล้วก็หัวหอมหรือ
ว่าคิดว่าผัดอันไหนที่เขาเนี่ยที่นาซ่า
ร้องนาซ่าแหละเอาไปปลูกนอกโลกได้เล่น
ตัวอย่างแรก
มีหัวหอมมันฝรั่งและแครอทแครอทว่าคิดว่า
อะไรที่นาซ่าเนี่ยเอาไปนอกโลกแล้วก็ปลูก
ว่าคิดว่าแครอทค่ะอยู่บ้านกินว่าแครอทน้ำ
แครอทไม่ชอบกินแครอทนะคะฝรั่งชอบกินแครอท
ใช่ไหมคะนาซ่าสอบกินแครอทดูซิว่าภูฟ้าจะ
ตอบถูกหรือผิด
ครูหญิงคณะผู้หญิงคณะครู sar แพ้ดื่มน้ำ
ค่ะ
หมดแล้วนะนาแก้วภูเขาก็ต้องเติมน้ำ
เต็มแก้วเป็นยาวไม่ได้ค่ะเท่านี้หมอนะฮะ
เยอะแล้ว
หัวหอมก็ไม่ใช่นะคะมันฝรั่งค่ะมันฝรั่ง
เนาะเขาเอาไปปลูกนอกโลก
part19 กู God กูไปยังไม่เกิดนะจริงๆอ่ะ
เพราะว่าเขาเอาไปปลูกเนี่ยเดือนตุลาคมปี
1995 นะคะครูฟ้ายังอยู่ในท้องคุณแม่
นาซ่าเท่าไหร่ na  SA หน่อยนะคะนาซ่า
เนี่ยเอาแครอท M แครอทมันฝรั่งนะคะไปปลูก
นอกโลกอิ่มไว้
คุณไม่ออกเวลาเนาะ
อ่ะกูถึงนอกโลกแล้ว
ครูฟ้าเห็นนั่งบินอวกาศใช่ไหมนานนะกินเอา
อันนี้เนี่ยเขาไปเหยียบดวงจันทร์
อันนี้นะมีอยู่อาร์มสตรองใช่ไหมนิวอามสอง
ล้อ New  Arm  Strong  Man นะคะไปเหยียบ
ดวงจันทร์อันนี้คือดวงจันทร์นะคะครั้งแรก
อีกครั้งแรกเนี่ย
ตีอะไรนะ 1986  8  1969 หรือว่า
ฟ้าบอกว่า
1969 นะ
สักครู่นี้นะ 1969 นะคะ
พอดูเฉลย
ถูกหรือผิด
Google
ครูฟังสนะครูหญิงแท้เราดื่มน้ำเข้ากัน
แล้วนะครูคะ
เฮ้ยเดี๋ยวให้ลงนะคะนักเรียนเริ่มอิ่ม
อิ่ม
สู้เขาแล้วผู้หญิงสู้
ๆวันนี้เสร็จผู้หญิงไม่ดื่มน้ำ 1 วันนะคะ
มาก
มาย 1  hour  6  9 อ่ะ
หมดหรือยังอ่ะเอานี้ดีกว่าถูกปากมากน่าจะ
ชอบอันนี้
รู้ใช่ไหม
เป็นอะไรที่เป็นสัตว์เนี่ยครูป่าเขาจะรู้
นะผู้หญิงมีข้อเเม้ไม่มีแล้วหมดแล้วนะฮะ
ครูฟ้าคะเวลาที่เราดื่มน้ำเรากินข้าว
เนี่ย
อ่าเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงของแอดเพจนี้หน่อยนะคะ
ได้ไหมคนเรานอนแล้วก็ลงไปนะฮะแล้วก็เป็น
ตัวเนาะแล้วเราก็ลงมาที่นี่เราก็จะมี
กระเพาะนั้นก็เพราะ
อันนี้นะอันนี้คือเฉพาะใช่ไหมเวลาเรากิน
อาหารก็จะลงไปในกระเพาะคนเนี่ยนะคะมี
กระเพาะเนี่ย 1 ช่อง 1 ช่องคือมีหนึ่ง
กระเพาะแล้วก็มี 1 ช่องเท่านั้น
แต่คำถามเนี่ยไม่ใช่คนนะคะถามแต่ว่า
ถามว่าตัวอะไรคะครูฟ้า
งูว่าฮัก your เนี่ยมีกระเพาะเท่าไหร่
มี 2 มี 4 แล้วก็มี 6 ครูฟ้าต้องไม่รู้กู
ฟ้าต้องไม่รู้กูหญิงต้องฉันนะมึงต้องฉัน
นะ
เรียนรู้ไหมคะนักเรียนรู้ไหมว่าวัวมี
กระเพาะเท่าไหร่อะไรบ้างอะไรบ้าง
เฉพาะของหวานกระเพาะของคาวอ้าวกลัวมี
กระเพาะเท่าไหร่คะครูฟ้า
หัวมี 4 กระเป๋า
เฉพาะน่ารักมาดูว่าครูฟ้าจะถูกหรือผิดถ้า
ครูฝาทุครูหญิงแพ้ดื่มน้ำ
ใครแพ้เองดื่มน้ำไง
2  3
นี่นะเดี๋ยวขอผู้หญิงดื่มน้ำก่อนนะคะ
ผู้หญิงกะดื่มน้อยลงเรื่อยๆนะคะนักเรียน
หญิงดื่มน้ำนะคะดื่มน้ำเยอะๆ
ควายก็มีสีกระเพาะนะคะจ่ายค่ะอ่าเรามาดู
ก็เพราะนักเรียนบอก 4 ตรงไหนใช่ไหมคะมัน
ก็จะมีนี้หัน 1
3 แล้วก็อันนี้ 4 นะคะมั้ยมีเขาจะแบ่ง
เป็น 4 มันไม่เหมือนกันนะผู้หญิงจำไม่ได้
ชื่ออะไรบ้างนะคะแต่ว่าวัวมี 4 กระปุกมี
กระเพาะสีช่องหรือว่ามี 4 กระเพาะนะไม่
ใช่สองมาเก่งมากล่ะวีดีโอนี้ครูฟ้าก็ดี
อาบน้ำไป 3 ครั้งตามครั้งหน้าผู้หญิงดื่ม
น้ำ 4 ครั้งก็คือผู้หญิงแท้สีครั้งชนะ 3
ครั้ง
ฟ้า
3 ครั้งชนะ 4 ครั้งใจว่าแพ้ดื่มน้ำนะนัก
เรียนล่ะคะยืมบอกให้นักเรียนเล่นไปกับเรา
ด้วยเนอะแล้วก็เล่นก็ได้นะคะ Reverse
กลับไปนะแล้วก็เล่นอ้าวก็ไม่รู้แล้วแต่
ว่าวีดีโอนี้หมดเวลาแล้วนะคะเดี๋ยวเราเจอ
กันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะอ่า